[Music]
before we get going if you enjoy what we
do on spectator tv
then do subscribe to our youtube channel
you do this by clicking the button at
the bottom of the video
and then tapping the bell icon to make
sure you never miss an episode ever
again
and why not subscribe to the spectator
magazine 2 while you're at it
get 12 weeks of the magazine for just 12
pounds and we'll give you a free 20
pound amazon voucher
completely free do the maths there and
that's three months of the spectator
delivered to your door
and available online for just 12 pounds
did we mention the voucher
just go to spectator dot co d uk forward
slash tv offer to take it up
now to covert to the surprise of many
covert cases across the uk
are on the decline could the pandemic
really be coming to an end
have you reached heard immunity or are
people just getting a little bit too
excited too early
professor sinetra gupta from the
university of oxford is on the show now
sinetra thanks for coming on ministers
are taking hope from the fact there is
now a clear damage trend in covered
cases
what do you think is behind it and is
this good news
uh well i think that of course it's good
news because
um what what it does is it starts
what it does is it allows us to start
thinking about
the different hypotheses about why cases
go
up or down at all and where we were at
last year
was a situation where we didn't have
enough data uh naturally the
the experiments hadn't been done to help
us discriminate
between two different hypotheses
and that's where the battle has been um
over the last
you know year or so is um in trying to
determine which of the two
competing hypotheses is correct
and what i said you know a year and a
half ago
now almost was really that we should be
extremely cautious about using
mathematical models to predict
the course pandemic and also
to make policy decisions because
what we have here now is from
various countries arise and fall
and interesting epidemic pandemic
patterns
and as i've said there are two competing
hypotheses
about why these are happening one is
that they're entirely due
to the effects of
masks and lockdowns and other
non-pharmaceutical
interventions and we've seen a lot of
models
that have appeared to validate that but
they don't actually what they do
is they throw out a testable hypothesis
about whether these things work or not
on the other end of the spectrum we have
several groups including our own saying
that well actually
we have to also consider the effects of
naturally acquired immunity of herd
immunity of seasonality
and factors that are not related to
these
imposed restrictions the truth of course
lies somewhere in between
but both of these activities are
actually just hypothesis
generating activities so you know that
it could be the um non-pharmaceutical
interventions it could be
herd immunity seasonality only data
can tell us where we lie within
that continuum and what i would say now
is we have what we we're seeing with the
cases falling
now or this downward trend is that
the effects of these npis are limited
and the main drivers
are actually naturally acquired immunity
in the population or
to obviously now vaccine induced
immunity which is unfortunately
probably quite transient but it's there
the signature is there and seasonality
and we've had a piece on coffee heads
this week by oliver johnston the
statistician
and he has uh ultimately said that it
might be
too early to celebrate or not in a way
don't get ahead of ourselves when it
comes to making predictions
in terms of the uh where the third wave
is over because it could in a way be
peaks and troughs
and he's talking about a local maxim
compared to
a global one and something we saw in
bolton where
cases went down and then they went back
up so
do you think this means it's too early
to really know what's going on given
that
if we look at the 19th of july easing
that wouldn't necessarily feed in just
yet
absolutely not i think that what's
happening here
is you have and something that's been
ignored is that there is a lot of
there are regional differences so it
makes absolutely
i agree with oliver in that it doesn't
make any sense
to make grand sweeping statements on the
basis of country-wide data
so you know last year people were saying
oh there's only six percent
serum positivity in the country and
there are two things wrong with that
one is that they were not taking into
account that antibody levels decline
very rapidly after infection and
more pertaining to the question you just
asked there is no point
lumping together all the data from
different regions
and our own work showed last year that
while um
people may have been highly exposed in
london for example
it was clear that scotland had not
suffered
the same level of exposure
and probably lockdowns consolidated that
so yes and not surprisingly that's where
we saw
infections creep up immediately as soon
as restrictions started to be lifted
so it's not as complicated as people
want to think it is now that they're
very
simple models only including um
farm interventions and restrictions
don't explain it
it is still simple but it it is a simple
mix
of herd immunity seasonality
and some effect of these
non-pharmaceutical interventions as well
as a transient effect of
vaccine-induced immunity on blocking
infection
now just to be clear vaccine induced
immunity is fantastic and hopefully
long i mean durable lifelong when it
comes to protecting against
severe disease and death but i suspect
some of the increase that we see
seeing now is due to the waning of
the infection blocking part of
vaccine-induced immunity
and i think one of the reasons it feels
as though
many investments also scientists and
scientific advisors have been caught by
surprise on the drop in daily cases
we've seen in parts of the week
so we've had quite bold predictions so
you had professor neil ferguson i think
just around a week ago saying it was
almost certain to reach a hundred
thousand cases a day
and there was a good chance actually you
could even get to two hundred thousand a
day
now they've dropped uh uh you know below
fifty
uh you know we're looking at twenty
something thousand a day in some cases
what do you think
uh has led that person to make such a
bold prediction
um when that is not corresponding with
that what we're seeing now
as i've said over and over again and
then my whole um you know involvement in
all of this from march of last year was
to stress that models
are absolutely crucial and invaluable
as tools for generating testable
hypotheses
they should never be used to predict
and also police while they should be
used as a basis
for formulating policy they should not
there
they should not be treated as
truth in any sense so what we have our
different hypotheses as i said we've got
a hypothesis that lockdowns work and
everything
uh you know is is do all the uh
fluctuations we're seeing
are due to these mandated
restrictions and then on the other hand
we have this other hypothesis
that maybe they are due to natural
immunity accruing in the population
despite these restrictions
and only data can tell us where the
truth lies
i think the data right now are telling
us that natural immunity
herd immunity plays an enormous role in
a
very important role in bringing down
infection
and we've seen that over the world i
mean all over the world there are places
where
lockdowns are effectively impossible to
implement
and we know that natural immunity plays
can even in those circumstances bring
infections down now what of course we
needed to do was recognize all of that
and come up with a policy that was
robust to all these uncertainties
and what we suggested last year which
was to
focus protection on the vulnerable would
have done that it would have avoided
all the uncertainties um that models
have
in in terms of actually throwing up real
numbers
about how things are going to be so
what's happening now is not
a surprise there are different models
different hypotheses
the data coming in what we need to do
now instead of
arguing amongst ourselves is just to sit
back and say
okay which of the different competing
hypotheses
do these data support it's a rational
exercise that should be executed with
calm
and without this idea that there is some
sort of conservation of virtue
here and that someone just because
someone was wrong or right
when it came to the hypothesis that they
are either a good or bad person
do you think then that perhaps when
we're having these debates and
particularly
uh with cobard we're hearing more when
it comes to these hypotheses
you know competing theories um that
there is a responsibility as opposed to
to be a little bit less certain in the
language we use um because it's
interesting because overnight nate silva
so
uh the famous us uh pollster uh who has
got many things in his right
right in this time but also something's
wrong has been quite critical of neil
ferguson's language
uh saying that uh you shouldn't have a
situation where someone is uh
so uh keen to say that they're definite
when you're doing
predictions um just because it is such a
complicated thing to do
it's not it's not complicated it's just
that
there is a confusion between hypothesis
and prediction
uh the models that kneel and and all
that the so-called mainstream um
modeling community were producing were
all um
generally self-consistent hypotheses
about how mandated npis might
bring down infection so they in those
models they
assumed that closing schools would have
some effect and then they
fed it into the model and they showed
that that could indeed
explain some of the patterns that
they had that were had been observed to
that up to that point
so what they actually were doing were
producing
a self-consistent testable hypotheses
now where that went wrong and people
started treating them as
predictions i don't know and it's not
for me to assign
blame on that but it was not right
that's
not part of the scientific procedure
what they should always have been
presented as
were testable hypotheses as indeed
on our side saying that look we think
that
actually a lot of this is due to
the accumulation of herd immunity and
seasonality that too is a hypothesis
so what we need to do now is all sit
back and just
say uh let's wait for the data to come
in
and then we can decide which of these
is more likely to be correct and in the
meantime
we need to follow policies that are
robust as i said to these uncertainties
and
also a cognizant of the huge harm done
by
um such measures as lockdown and and
these
these are all simple precepts uh i think
people are
falling back upon oh it's all very
complex we can't do this you can't do
that
well we knew that you'd never use models
to make specific predictions you use
them
to generate testable hypotheses they did
that
we did that now let's wait and see what
the data say
[Music]
you